[APPLAUSE]
Hamdi, welcome
to the GSB.
We are so excited to have you here.
>> Thank you.
Thank you so much.
This is so hard.
[LAUGH]
>> Just a little extra challenge.
Well, campus has been
buzzing with your arrival.
And in fact, there's actually
been a bit of a debate about
what is the best flavor of Chobani Yogurt.
So in this true spirit of business school,
I set out to do a bit of
market research and polled the class to
see what was the most popular flavor.
So out of strawberry, peach,
blueberry and raspberry,
Hamdi, would you like to
guess which flavor won?
>> Blueberry.
>> Blueberry?
Well, actually strawberry won.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But that's okay.
We at the GSB love to be outliers,
so it's okay, I understand.
Well, and then here's some
behind the scenes footage.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If you'd like to use these as
marketing materials, feel free.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In preparation for our conversation,
I learned that Chobani can be
loosely translated to shepherd.
Can you tell us about
the significance there?
>> Sure, and your background is Greek, as
I understood just now which is beautiful.
And I don't know if you speak Greek but
it also sounds like Chobani but
I won't kill it.
It's like [FOREIGN] something like
this and in Turkish it's coban.
And by the way,
I want to say Madhava to my Turkish
brothers and sisters, they're here.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And, of course, all of you,
I'm just homesick, but
then I grew up on
the Eastern part of Turkey.
Northeast and Nomad, a tribal life.
So my earliest memories are with
shepherds and coban means shepherds.
So my earliest memories are all shepherds,
shepherd stories.
Interaction with shepherds,
family members being shepherds.
I was too little but being eager to go
with them to the caring for the animals.
So when I was looking for name,
I was traveling from Chicago to Madison,
Wisconsin.
And the reason for that is I drove from
that road to go to this old equipment
dealership in Madison, Wisconsin.
So I can buy this separator when
it's essential to make Greek
yogurt to separate liquid from the mass.
[COUGH] And in that drive, I don't know
if any of you have done that drive.
It's a very boring drive,
it's a long drive.
Not much radios work, and
it's 2006, I don't know if I was bored or
if it was the Christian radio I
was listening that they were talking
about shepherds all the time.
I came up with the name Chobani at that
drive and when I came back to Chicago and
I looked it up and chobani.com was
available and that's how we came up.
>> Amazing.
Well, we've learned in a lot of our
classes and case studies the importance of
a brand connection and that brand history
and you obviously have a fantastic one.
>> Yeah, and I really be, I started
Shepherds Give foundation day one.
A lot of people don't
know what meanings of it.
Inside the company, people do know.
But they had significance for me was okay,
Chobani sounds really nice,
as a sound, it sounds nice.
But then the emotional,
the weight of that word for
me was,
you look at it throughout the history and
we can call it the new shepherds now.
But you look at throughout the generations
of humankind, we look up to shepherds and
represented pureness,
it represented unconditional giving,
it represented humanity,
safety and wisdom.
And I have seen those in my own
experience as a growing up.
So I thought,
if I can bring the elements of those,
right from the beginning with the name,
into this company that I'm launching
it would be a great success.
And I have no idea how long would I go.
I had no idea how far I would make it or
if I would be able to put
elements of it in there.
But my personal connections, but
also that was the idea that
Chobani worked with well.
>> Mm-hm, well, it all started
on a small farm in Turkey, but
now obviously Chobani has
found incredible success.
There are countless business ideas and
aspiring founders out there,
who are all trying to
create the next big thing.
In your opinion, what are some of the key
magical ingredients that help create
a breakthrough company that scales?
>> Wow.
And, I have to be very honest,
I did not have a previous knowledge or
experience of business.
So, my earlier expense is as I
said the shepherds later on,
I went to university in Ankara,
became an activist, started publishing
newspapers and got into trouble with
the government and I had to get out.
Some experience with the police
station but then out.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then I found myself in upstate
New York working in a farm.
So basically,
I was home again in upstate New York and
not necessarily know what I was
going to do with my life, and
there was not a massive urgency of
what I'm going to do with my life.
One thing that I can tell about myself,
and not in a bragging way is,
I was never nervous about life.
Not that I had anything about it, but
I didn't have this urgency of,
I have to do this, or I have to do this.
I always had, growing up,
being up into those Muslim mountains
where we grow up as nomads,
I was always wondering what was
behind the tallest mountain that
we could see from our tents.
And I had that curiosity that,
what would be beyond those mountains?
So, my journey was always, I wonder
what life is going to be bringing,
so, I'm just going to go.
And I found out later on
that I was never rigid.
Like I'd never made plans that
would stop me from changing it,
going this direction or that direction.
I was in a city trying
to learn English and
teacher said I had a farm upstate
New York, I went up there.
She said, Do you want to stay here?
I said sure, then I stay.
And I became a farmer for
a year and a half.
And then somebody said there is
a economic development side that they
support businesses.
And I went there and they said,
Do you want to make cheese?
I said, yeah,
I'd like to make some cheese.
[LAUGH] And then later on I saw an ad and
said, fully equipped yogurt plant for
sale, and
I said I'll go take a look at it.
That evening and
I went to look at the plans.
Right then I said, you know what,
I'll buy this place.
Despite the fact everybody
says you don't have money,
you have no idea what you're thinking.
There's a big companies leaving,
but I was just curious,
what would it be like from that
emotion that I had in that plant?
So I'm not in a position to say
What makes our businesses to scale?
Because I've seen enormous, enormous
businesses in front of my eye to start and
grow, became extremely powerful.
But I can tell you what
makes joy in business.
If you're a founder, and
if you are the starting
person in the journey.
I can tell you that you could
have enormous amount of
experiences through this and
for me it is tremendous.
I'm a kid from the shepherd's,
I traveled 1000 years,
I feel like I traveled 1000 years.
If you look at my early days, I'm in a
tribe where tradition has not changed for
hundreds of hundreds of years now it's
changed, shepherds have cell phones.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But back then when I left,
it was the same way they made the butter.
It was the same way they did the weddings.
It was the same way they grieve.
It was the same way they interacted
socially with each other.
It had not had changed so dramatically
only time that they would go see somewhere
outside of the town when we get sick or
they went to military service.
But outside of that it was the same thing.
So for me it's been an amazing journey and
I had to adjust as I went through.
But at the true joy,
true power of business comes when
you see that it has a direct
impact on people's life.
And as it gets successful and
bigger It becomes extremely powerful,
and this I had no idea
about this until I started.
Now, what I can tell you on that one,
is if you want to
make business joyful, but
also very successful,
it has to be embedded very,
very early on day one.
And it truly needs to be embedded
early on, and then becomes magical.
But we just don't know how
things comes into life,
you just don't know how
you find solutions.
People will give you credits
99% of it is not you.
It's the environment that you created or
you've been part of to be created,
that inputs come from left and
right ideas come from left and right.
People become heroes,
people become solution makers.
And it becomes this
magical environment and
I always said It's elevated environment.
So how do you make
an elevated environment?
Yeah, money is good, and
you can do a lot of things with it, and
people get excited about it.
The people I hired that they let go
in the factory in that old factory,
that the old factory old company,
they just fire them,
left them behind and just left.
This is another topic that you
could talk about for hours.
Those same companies
are going to be millionaires.
Maybe lawyer said I shouldn't be
saying this-
>> [LAUGH]
>> But the factory workers, right?
But I couldn't motivate them,
if I told them work with me,
I'm going to make you a millionaire.
Maybe, but not that great.
But if you create an environment and
say, these people left you and
these people left us,
these people left this factory children,
this community, this farmers, and
I've seen this happen where I come from.
This is the responsibility of
businesses happening everywhere.
And there is an answer to this we can
go out and scream and protest and
all that kind of stuff.
Or even though we don't have money,
even though we don't have experience, even
though we don't have network, even though
we don't have that kind of capability.
But we can put ourselves together
in this tiny little town,
in this very old factory, and we could
dream that this factory can become
one of the biggest factory in
this country next five years.
And we could dream that we could be
number one brand in this country and
we can kick those people ass
who closed this factory and
we can give the answer to them this way.
And you can talk to pure poor
factory workers that way and
if you truly act upon it, you can make
them believe as much as you believe.
And then magic starts happening.
Now in that moment, if you say
physically this is not possible.
Because in order for you to be
a number one brand in five years, or
a billion dollars in sales in
five years from this old factory.
You will have 16 to 18 lines,
those lines are 400 to
600 cups per minute.
They will cost anywhere 5 to $10 million,
and
they will take about two years to build.
So then in order to have them,
you make the calculations,
in five years,
this is literally impossible.
So if you're going to make it five years,
you're probably going to
be 2 million cases a week.
That means a pallet of
yogurt every 15 seconds.
Now when you talk about it,
it's a quiet place there's
nobody there it's an old place.
[SOUND] You can dismiss the idea and you
say you're not going to to be a billion
dollars in sales in business in five
years and stay 100% independent.
And you will find all the money
you needed to make this happen
that you don't have to
raise penny of capital and
then you will give the answer
to the world impossible.
But then slowly start happening,
toilets turn into office,
parking lot turns into a cooler
space with the trailers.
You find used fillers somewhere else and
people find it in their
nighttime talkings.
And we literally turn that
place into that place, and
I had no previous experience of doing so.
So what I can tell you
in a short answer is,
I found magic and purpose.
And I found magic and
an amazing harmonation of love and anger.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's okay to be angry,
I've been angry all my life.
But if we can channel it
through in a very positive way,
that becomes an enormous energy.
And the result of it,
I can't put a price of the joy and
benefit that you get from it.
Is one of the most beautiful
thing that I've been part of,
of that business effect on people's life?
>> Well, clearly, a lot of magic happened
in that old factory that you found,
a 95-year-old craft factory, and
you decided to take out a small
business loan-
>> Yeah
>> To purchase the factory to start
producing the yogurt.
At the GSB, we talk a lot about
venture capital and I'm curious about
your decision to take a small
business loan versus raise VC money.
>> Well, I didn't know about that world.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I swear I didn't know.
>> And I saw this old factory and
I started wondering how I can buy this.
And there was this
KeyBank's local Johnston,
New York KeyBank regional sales guys,
representatives, Pat Moochie and
John Ryder, Pat Moochie passed away and
John Ryder is still out there.
And I told them,
I want to do the right thing.
John Ryder thought that was a crazy idea,
it's stupid.
Pat Moochie this Sicilian Italian
guys most heavy big guy and
says, I believe you.
You gotta do something I don't know what
but you're going to do something I'm
going to help you out and says, you have
this SBA loan if you can make a business
plan And you come up with 40%
of the funding that needed.
I'm sorry, if you can come up 10% of
the funding that needed, with the bank
will come up with 40%, and the SBA
will provide the 50% loan guarantee.
So we can fund a million bucks,
we can buy this factory.
So the factory was $700,000 and
I needed $300,000 to start it.
So I wrote my first [LAUGH] business plan,
and basically,
that's what they did for
me to buy that factory.
Later on, I got calls from 2009, 2010.
My fear was not that I want
to keep everything to myself.
My fear was, if I bring somebody in,
will they affect me?
One, to crowd my head with unnecessary
noises and voices and talks, and
all that kind of stuff.
The second one is, will they force me
to do things that I don't want to do?
So I try so hard to keep it simple,
keep it pure,
and the business really
performed from 2007 October.
And by 2009,
I kept the business so simple.
I mean, I was in QuickBooks
until $670 million in sales.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm not kidding.
And then since they changed it,
I have no idea what the business is now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I understood everything about business
until $700 million.
>> [LAUGH] That's fair.
>> But I kept it so simple and
I realized that, and
I still give that fight at Chobani today,
it's there's
a lot of unnecessary noises
that happens in boardrooms,
in factory floors, in titles,
and all that kind of stuff.
So I kept it extremely simple and
I'm still given that fight,
and I was very cost oriented.
I was a factory worker, I did not
leave that factory for seven years,
more than three days, maybe a month or
so for some sales calls.
And I was so into every single details of
happening in the factory and the product,
and every single detail
that you can think of.
I mean, I was little crazy,
maybe I was a little bit too much.
And there you would find opportunities,
problems about to happen, or
solution that you need to come up with.
And so that kept it really profitable,
so I didn't have to raise any capital.
>> But you took a bet on yourself and
on your ability to bring Greek
yogurt to the United States and
it obviously definitely paid off.
But it's easy to forget that in 2010,
there were no Greek yogurt
brands being advertised on TV.
And then two years later,
there were eight different brands,
what did that competition do to you?
>> [LAUGH] I knew it was coming, and
that's what I said to anybody who
come up with the idea of the food
items in the United States.
Especially in the United States,
it's a very, very challenging environment.
And I saw this very, very early on.
So there's the separation
between specialty stores and
the mass market in the United States.
But if you go to let's say Turkey, Europe,
any other countries there
are some middle market companies.
There are regional businesses.
There are businesses that are not so
big but not too small.
They have capability to
supply regionally or cross.
And those are almost don't
exist in this country,
if you're countrywide,
system wide mass food maker.
So, early on, I really understood that
the big guys they never make innovations.
They don't have to.
So when I started,
you have a cup Dannon or
a cup of Yoplait at the time.
You look at it, 25 grams sugar.
I mean, you have the ingredients
from top to bottom.
I don't know if you guys
remember those days.
And they were advertising all day
long how healthy this stuff is.
And then the cost is extremely cheap.
All the factories are made
to make those cups, and
they have all the reasons to
keep that things that way.
So you don't want anyone to disrupt that.
And if you look at mass food environment
in this country, which is the reason of
a lot of problems that we're facing today,
when it comes to health.
Is hold by large corporations,
large food corporations,
that have massive supply chain capability.
And enormous amount of one to one
relationship with the retailers,
that those are maybe 10,
maybe 12 companies that hold vast majority
of food that produced and
consumed in this country.
Because for startups, it's extremely
difficult to create those capabilities.
So you can be a true partner with
Walmart or Kroger or Safeway.
So what you become is a specialty player.
So specialty like Whole Foods and
all those classes,
it's only maybe less
than 5% of the market.
So 95% of the market is on the mass.
So when somebody comes,
I have a great idea.
Good, so you just worked so
hard for two years to create it and
then you went knocked door and
door in all these specialty stores and
prove that this works.
And the big guys come for two questions,
one is do you want to sell?
And sometimes you're forced to
sell because all the capital
that you raised until that idea come
to life, and when it comes to food,
it's very, very capital heavy.
They come with questions,
you want to sell?
Do you love what you do?
Four time sales,
five times sales, whatever it is.
But then they come to second half,
if you don't, I'll make the same thing.
It's not your idea anymore,
it's everybody's idea, so
it goes into a big guy's ability.
Let's say oat milk came up, but
how many oat milk is out there, right?
Everybody can make the oat milk now.
So basically, when you have the supply
chain, you can be immune to competition,
if your brand is very, very strong, and
your value proposition is very strong,
and there's something unique about you.
But if you don't have the supply chain,
you got no place to go.
So what I said when I saw them I
said they're going to come, and
before they come,
I have to make two decision.
Either I want to stay small, Or
I have to pass certain level that
they cannot hurt me anymore.
And I bet on the second one.
So at that time, they were so
slow, by the time they came up,
I was already 6, $700 million sales.
And I was distributed across the country,
and I was building a plant in Idaho.
But when they came, they came really,
really, really hard.
Because you've just embarrassed one of
the largest yogurt makers in the world.
In a very bad way, so they say
[LAUGH] I understand somebody come
up with an idea and make some nice noises
in Whole Foods, in all those places.
But now I'm losing shares in Stop & Shop,
in Costco, this not nice.
So I always tell my colleagues,
they have an incubator,
and say you have to focus on
manufacturing fundamentals,
then you are in the food business.
So at Chobani, people think that
I built a yogurt and flavors.
90% of the time I spent,
its factories, supply chain,
these boring details that
nobody wants to talk about.
But in the end, if you're going to
disrupt any category in this country,
Which has not been disrupted in
a massive way if you look at it.
You have to focus on the supply chain.
>> Well, clearly you were able
to disrupt the the industry and
rise above the competition, all the while
still focusing on the human spirit and
not just focusing on the spreadsheets,
as you've said before.
And an incredible example of that,
of not just looking at the spreadsheets,
is your decision to grant
shares to all 2,000 employees,
including factory workers, in 2016.
I'm sure there were some people who were
not thrilled with that decision, but
you made it anyway.
What was your thinking there?
>> I always said, and
it's still considered like as
if I'm the nice guy, I give a gift.
And I have seen this unjust
from me growing up and
becoming a young adult in university and
this in Turkey and
later on here,
is responsibility of business.
What I saw in that little town is that
factory was there for, like you said,
80, 95 years.
When the things were good,
the steam was coming off from the chimney,
and the products were coming and the
trucks were coming and people had jobs.
When things didn't look good,
somebody made a decision in
the headquarter that if we cut off
this business and you'll save so
much money, and those people left behind.
So why is this factory workers,
and in this pandemic we saw,
we call them frontline workers,
but who are they?
You had really truck drivers,
factory workers, nurses and
all those people that,
some of them are parents,
some of it are relatives,
that they move the society forward.
But when the bad days comes in business,
they're the first one to be blamed.
So in my scenario, 4 factory workers,
later on 10, later on 50,
later on 100 with me,
we built that things back together.
I've never made that promise because I
didn't know if I could make that false
promise.
I didn't know if I would be succeed,
so I don't want to give some.
But when I knew that we had it,
it was the decision I made day one
that everyone who worked to build this
have right to have a share of it or
part of the success
that we have generated.
And I truly believe in this new
way of looking at business and
what it means in society where
it comes an enormous amount of
strong effect on how society moves forward
and businesses are behaving that way.
But this income inequality
between working people and
people on top even in this country
is getting deeper and sharper.
And that's the only way you can save
that is, governments can do policies and
all that kind of stuff.
But if we can make businesses to share
its success with the stakeholder and
most importantly, if it is workers,
is the only way moving forward.
And I hope that this becomes a very normal
practice, not that you brag about it.
It's the same way all the startups
that happen here in Silicon Valley,
it's a very common things.
But it's not common when it comes to
the vast majority of service industry,
manufacturing industry and
especially in our food industry.
>> You've said before that social
impact needs to be a key part of
a company's DNA and you clearly
represent that from the top down.
But do you have some examples of how
that's represented from the bottom up?
>> How it's represented from bottom up,
if you could give an example.
>> So the kind of impact that
maybe a factory worker can
have on making social impact
part of the identity.
>> Yeah, I think
There's this magic word, culture,
and I've I've seen a lot of things
that people talk about culture.
People talk about all this diversity,
inclusion,
things that we offer, what's in
the handbook of employee handbooks and
what do you write in the walls and
all that kind of stuff.
A funny thing about culture is it's
either real or it's just not there,
or it's just in the walls and
it's in the papers.
When it's real, then everybody
is committed to be part of it.
There is this unspoken rule that
starts happening in that environment.
And for the founders, you'll be a founder,
a lot of people will be founder here,
is that cultures are built mostly
in the very early beginning.
So I'd say the first few years, and
what happens in the first few years is
you are very intensely together and
it's very close, and
there's a lot of conversation happens.
And you face a lot of challenges,
and you find a lot of solutions, and
then you kind of come too close to
almost die, finish the whole thing.
In those environments, the real you come
out, how you behave in those environments.
There's a recording is
happening during that time and
those stories being told later on forever.
So what I can say is my early
few years were so intense, and
I was so present, and
I'm so proud of myself.
I really am.
I'm not proud of a lot
of things I've done, but
I'm really proud of the first
few years that I was in there.
I was in a meeting in the second or
third year and I gather all our employees.
And these are all upstate New York,
Harley drivers, big guys, some of them.
And I brought them all in
the cafeteria and I said,
we just started something magical,
I can see this is going somewhere really,
really good, but
I'm not sure if I can handle this.
I have never been part of this before.
So I said I don't have anyone around me.
I don't have a mother.
I don't have wife.
I don't have girlfriend.
I don't have children.
I don't have family members, I'm alone.
So I have you, you're my family.
And if you see me I go in a wrong way,
if you see me, I act in a wrong way,
like nose up in the air,
start behaving like I'm a big guy,
big shot and start doing weird stuff.
I give permission every single
one of you to hit me on the face.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I literally said that and
there are some big guys.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I said,
you would give me a service if you do that
because I don't want this magic to done,
and I'm not sure if I can handle it,
I'm just a human being.
And nobody hit me.
>> Yet.
>> But-
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH] I think if I go
back there is Maria,
there is Rick,
there's Mike,
there's Frank.
I can name a lot of people in
that place that has significant,
Kyle, significant Impact on
Chobani as much as I am, but
their names are not
mentioned in newspapers and
they're not sitting here next to you.
So what I'm saying is,
if you create that culture,
every single individual
contributes as big as what you do.
>> Well, that's great and
you've shared their names here today and
I'm sure they really appreciate that.
Another area you've had amazing
impact is with refugees.
And 30% of Chobani's manufacturing
force are refugees or immigrants.
Unfortunately, not everyone is as
welcoming of these communities as you are.
So, could you maybe share a statistic or
an argument that you have found to be most
effective in convincing
people to change their minds?
>> I'm so happy you brought this up.
So, Tent came out of this experience
that I had in Upstate New York,
when we expand the factory, and
hire everybody that was let go before.
Expanded a little bit further and then hit
a town in Utica, which I used to live and
people said there are refugees
that settled in Utica.
And this is 2008, 2009 that area from
all across the world legally being
settled as refugees they're having
very much hard time to find jobs.
So, I went to the refugee agency,
and I said what's the problem?
Actually this heavenly lady, she said,
they don't speak the language,
they don't have cars,
they don't have trainings of
jobs that are available here.
But most importantly people really are,
little,
I said what, afraid of them or what is it?
People are not familiar with people coming
from Asia and Africa and Middle East,
this is a rural community.
I said, okay, I need workers.
I had everyone in my community that
is available, let's do something.
So we'll get some cars and buses,
we'll get some translators and
we see how that goes.
He said, are you sure?
I said, yeah, I think this will be good.
So, this started, not a refugee
work it was a community work.
Where people who are left behind,
left out,
and they have no way of getting in and
just breaking those barriers.
But just cars, translators,
and in job training,
it's an HR work really
it's not a big deal.
Just bring them in and
let people get to know each other and
interact with each other.
And it became this thing and it brought so
much energy to the company,
people loved it.
Brotherhood, sisterhood is built and
people have never had seen someone from
Nepal or someone from Ethiopia or
someone from South America.
And it was so magical, I just saw things
are happening, I couldn't believe my eyes.
So when I built a plant in Idaho,
did the same thing.
And then, we saw three years later,
four years later,
and people will come to me tell
me what their experiences,
I just bought home,
my daughter is in this school.
So, this magic of having
an access to job for
a refugee is the moment that
they stop being a refugee.
That is the only moment they start being
part of a community, they start being part
of a society, they can build their life
for themselves and for their children.
So I thought, how could I take this
experience that I had into a large scale.
So, I went to Geneva and talk to UNHCR and
IRC and some other things.
And what I'd realized,
the absence of business in this
refugee topic, which is probably one
of the most alarming humanitarian
crisis that we're facing today.
We have faced this during World War II,
when Europe had so much refugees,
especially Jewish refugees
are fleeing all over the world and
humanity did not perform
well at that time.
And this is again happening, and
it's happening other places.
And I thought the other
saddest thing is how
this topic is being part of
political conversations and
how it's profiled so unfairly, so bad.
And the only way you can cut this through
is if you can tie it into power of
brands and businesses and CEOs,
which today have more respect and
believability rates than anybody else.
So I launched it with Airbnb,
Joe has been amazing on this topic,
Airbnb has been amazing.
Mastercard, IG has been
amazing on this from very
early on and few others in Davos in 2016.
And what I said is,
we'll do scientific studies.
We've done a lot with Stern,
business schools, and some economists, and
branding people.
We did market research in each markets,
Europe, South America,
US, Canada and demographics.
And we said here, statistics are,
refugees are staying
in the job 30 to 40%
longer than anybody else.
Productivity level, and
we have done all these studies,
is twice more than anyone you will have.
And then, every dollar you spend
on refugees in five years,
the longest,
usually it's a lot earlier than that,
the longest in any society in five years
pays back and then positive after forever.
All these studies we've done, and
then be the marketing studies that say,
how people think about your brand and
your company, if you hire refugees,
train refugees, and you're pro refugees.
And we did all these market studies and
found that what it does to brand and
what it does to talent
coming into your company
when they know you're socially
active in the refugee field.
So one by one we convince
companies to come and join.
Today we are over 200 companies,
worldwide.
And when the Afghanis were coming,
refugees from Afghanistan
just a month ago.
We had over 60 companies signed
up publicly, very beautifully and
committing to hire refugees
train them right away.
So this coalition that we have built
together, it became extremely powerful.
It's the first business
coalition has been built.
Now, if you talk to anybody,
we've been to Colombia,
we've been to Canada, we've been to
refugee camps all over the world.
If you talk to the companies who
have gone into this business,
there's this enormous amount of effect
internally in the company that you have.
So it's really, really good for business.
And I don't find any other way other than
businesses coming into this topics and
any other topics that society is facing.
And make it part of the HR department,
part of their manufacturing and
people department, or service department.
And it's not check the box,
it's organically imbedded into operation,
that you can see the light
under the tunnel.
But it's very early beginning,
I am extremely passionate about it.
And I think these people have
gone through so much pain and
sorrow and difficulties that
they didn't want to leave,
they didn't want to go through this.
But now, they are in these un-stuck
places that human capacity and
potential through business
they can come into society,
they can come into their life and
rebuild their life.
And the businesses can benefit and
society can benefit from this.
So it's very simple,
hire them, Train them, and
use your supply chain to keep
them in wherever they are into
the supply chain, and
you'll benefit greatly.
>> I love that your answer has
statistics to back you up.
>> Absolutely.
>> But of course as always,
you're speaking from the heart and
focusing on the human spirit there.
And our theme for this slate of speakers
this year has been going beyond,
going beyond expectations of a CEO or
a leader.
And I think you've done an incredible
job of exemplifying that, so thank you.
>> Thank you and,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I'm so honored to be with you and
with you all.
I have not graduated from university so
I'm a,
>> Not yet.
>> [LAUGH] Not yet.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But,
enormous amount of respect
to this institution.
Enormous amount of respect
that solutions and
innovations in the way
that how to form humanity.
And society better through innovation and
business coming out into society.
You guys are inspiring us all,
it's the most amazing thing.
And, being here being with you is
something that I will not forget and
thank you for the invitation,
thanks for this moment.
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay,
we are now going to move to some
questions from the audience.
>> Thank you so much for
being here and inspiring us.
I love the comment about the joy, and
creating a culture from the beginning.
So my question to you is,
Chobani's doing so
much in trying to go forefront in so
many so many topics.
And, there are two things that capture
my attention when looking at what
they're doing.
One is, this incubator for new businesses
and when I first read I was wow,
they're actually funding other
companies who could be competition.
[LAUGH] So I wanted to ask you
a little bit about that initiative of
the incubator.
And also what would you like to see
more in the sector to help, move and
push this initiative forward?
>> What a beautiful question,
I find food in the US is one of
the fundamentals a problem
that we need to solve.
And, the problem is you can make food
that is very good ingredients, but
it's very expensive
people cannot afford it.
And and then the big guys they make
very bad food is very accessible.
So how do you make accessible food that
is wholesomely made, is nutrition made?
That every children every family
members across the country can have it.
So that was my thing is good food for
all, delicious,
nutritious, natural and accessible.
Because you can make $5 yogurt but,
how many people are going to buy that?
So, what I did is we found a way,
we found a way to make $1 a yogurt.
That made extremely wholesome
ingredients that have 11 gram protein.
That available in Walmart for $1 Kroger
for $1 20 that everybody can buy.
So I wanted to share that
with the startups, so
I started the incubator,
Chobani Incubator.
And I said no strings attached
I don't want anything back,
I don't want any percentage or anything.
All I want to do is,
if I was starting my journey in 2007,
the things that I wish I had known
back then, what would those be?
And I made a list of five,
kind of five or seven.
And I wanted to share those with people
who are starting their journey that had
the like minded entrepreneurs.
They have the right attitude,
and they see the same thing.
And we started this it became
very very popular, and
incubator people will come four months,
five months stay with us.
Engineering, quality,
plants, branding, marketing,
all the doors are open for all of them.
And we had amazing women founders came,
veterans founders came.
And the farmers and intrapreneurs came and
I started with 32,
I did it for four years.
I brought 30 students from Turkey
from all across the country and
then five, six startups every year.
That was the summer program, I think one
of the most beautiful thing we can do is
share the experience and knowledge,
without being any string attached.
And opening up so
the second reason I had is,
we cannot be alone on
this we need a community.
So that's the reason, either another
yogurt maker, another food maker,
whatever it is.
This new good food making movement for
all, has to be a communities for
us to be able to make a dent,
into this problem.
So I thought, we might not be
as big as the other big guys.
But if we are part of a community and
we collaborate with each other,
we share from each other,
then we can really make this a mass thing.
So that was the second reason
that I started it, yeah.
>> Hi Hamdi this is Mitad from Istanbul,
I'm also a fan [CROSSTALK] fan.
So, thank you so much for coming here and
sharing your insights about
entrepreneurship and impact.
And I would like to your comments
on being an international
immigrant entrepreneur in
the US was very important.
And was very, truly inspiring for
all the international students who
want to start businesses here.
And I would like to ask what
would be your top three tips for
them to start great businesses in the US?
>> What a great question with that,
Really get to know America.
And, what I can suggest for
people like us coming from outside.
For the Americans, there's politics,
there is celebrity, there is footballs and
all that kind of stuff,
that's a different thing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But for us, we come with pre-judgments,
and those judgments can be
because of what we read.
Because of the political background
we come from, whatever that might be.
And I tell this to refugees to
get rid of all those pre-ideas,
get to know America,
if this is what you want to live in.
And I say that because dismissal is
extremely easy like I don't like this,
I don't like what they do here,
I don't like what they do here.
But if you look at it for
the large part, we are the same, right?
So, when I went upstate
New York walked in that farm,
in New York City I couldn't there's more
Turks in New York City than natives.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
it's Turkey in New York City
if you want to stay in Turkey.
But, when I was upstate New York, these
farmers the people have been there for
generations you get to know the soil.
You get to know the culture,
you get to know the background.
And start loving apple pie,
>> [LAUGH]
>> And,
Thanksgiving the magic of Thanksgiving,
I was amazed by it.
Interactions of the farmers with
each other, I was amazed by it.
And, And I celebrated those a lot.
And when I start celebrating then I
started to get to know the people and
the culture and the history.
And I think in the entrepreneurship,
there's a little bit of anthropology,
is really involved in it.
And that is your own
experience with people,
without the judgement, to understand.
And people look at Chobani they think
we are very liberal activist brand.
You have to understand, our two plans
in up state New York, and Idaho,
they're are 70% red states, red areas.
And these are one of my closest brothers,
and sisters.
We made human connections because
we understood each other.
I still make my argument that there should
be minimum wage with the Idaho government.
I still make an argument that when
they ban transgenders in schools and
I strongly disagree with that.
But in a human level we understand each
other we can sit down and break bread and
talk about things.
And I can still celebrate the deep
culture of Idaho in a feminine level and
in other other levels.
So what one of my recommendation
is truly try to understand, and
you'll find more beauty
than you ever imagined.
Especially in the rural areas,
especially in the family interactions,
is there some not so good things?
Of course, it's everywhere.
And the second one is,
don't try to be like them.
Stay who you are, what you brought
where you come from are so beautiful,
so amazing and so valuable, and this
country celebrates that in tremendously.
So how do you make sure that what you see,
and
what you bring that can beautifully
homogenize with each other?
I never forget being a shepherd
son from eastern part of Turkey,
I never forget that boy.
And if I go back tomorrow and if I put
a mask on and nobody recognize me,
I can go to that mountain, and
start being under that tent, and
be with the shepherds and
they would never know I left.
Because I never forgot that I
live that every single day.
So you don't have to leave who you are to
become successful for another place.
The most successful person is brings
the beauty of where you come from,
and to take and homogenize it here.
And I always said I brought
a seed from but I come and
I found the beautiful soil here and
that's become this plant.
>> It's beautiful.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hamdi hi, my name is Yvonne,
thank you so much for
being here, I'm a second year.
In the 45 or 50 minutes we've been with
you, you've connected so well with us.
And I'm curious as a CEO and founder,
do you draw lines with your people?
And if so, when do you do that and
how do you know what lines to draw?
>> Thank you, look, thank you
I was smiling under my mask.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so so gracious, thank you so much.
Yes, look as long as they know
they're real, it's okay to be angry,
it's okay to draw the lines,
it's okay to have tough conversations.
And as long as it's not personal,
I always said,
I mean my colleague Michelle is
here [LAUGH] and I love him.
We've done wonders together, and
we have tough times together.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And as long as he knows I'm angry about
the thing not at him and
we have not written a lot of
rules in the company but
it's a lot of knowns.
One thing that I have know,
I have know patience for is disrespect,
but just either in a social environment or
inside the company
to talk about one of your colleagues
in a very disrespectful way.
Or making somebody uncomfortable
in this space is something that I
think that is poison in business field,
if it ever exists.
And I mean, that is one of them.
Second one is, when somebody
suggest preservatives in food.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's just no,
that shit is not going to happen.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I think, introduction of poison in
a very small way in the business field,
and
sometimes it's just a tiny thing.
Those things later on grows and
becomes a really big thing.
And I have relaxed certain
things along the way,
which I thought that was
really big thing for
that time but not necessarily right now.
Like I had this thing that,
if I open a cup of yogurt, and
if I see yogurt on the lid, I'll get so
upset that people were so scared of it.
So I will go to the store and
I open the yogurt on the lid and
that means that we've not
done our filling right.
Those fillers were so so fast,
so I would go and give so
much bad time for our operation people.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then I give up,
I said who give shit about.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it's okay there's trucks, and
there's people if they buying it,
if they put in the shopping bag,
it's going to happen anyway.
So there are things that
is not realistic but,
I really do believe they're
having real conversation.
Sometimes not pleasant conversation,
is totally fine and
totally okay, we're not a foundation,
we are real business.
And I always want to tell people
I'm not an NGO, this is not an NGO,
this is a business, and
it has to self sufficient itself.
And every year 10% of the people
will leave let go or fired,
whatever that is just
function of business.
And I think we need to know that,
if you're going to build a society
where business finds a way to solve
this fundamental problems and
be part of it, you cannot behave
like an NGO, it's real business.
And I don't know if you want to put
a tagline of his social enterprise or
this and that.
I don't have to sound like I'm from
church or I'm from Save America or
Save the Children.
I don't have to, I'm business, I innovate,
I compete, I don't like my competitors.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If they're so
good I'll find a way to hate
them one way or another.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Kidding aside,
this is the excitement part of
business that gets me going is,
I can think about things how I
can win the battles in the shelf.
For the right reason it
makes it even better, but
the field of business is something that
you will not find in anybody else, but
you can put all your capability,
leadership, innovation,
human connection, interaction teamwork,
I don't know, you name it.
That the place that you touch, it's just
amazing especially if you're a founder or
if you're a founding partner.
So it's an amazing place, so
let's keep it business but,
there has to be a silent language.
Knowledge, or conviction or
everyone agrees,
that we operate this
within these boundaries.
We know why we do what we do,
we don't have to talk about and
brag about it all the time.
We know that we are safe and
we are all together, and
this is our space everybody's in here.
And we know that we have some certain
performance that we have to do it.
And if we don't,
it's not going to be punished with we're
going to find a way to do it together.
But those boundaries can be created, and
within that we'll have some pleasant
conversation, and some not pleasant
conversation I think that's totally fine.
>> Thank you to the students for
those great questions.
Hamdi, I noticed that you often wear
what is important to you on your head.
And so in honor to honor your
time with us here today,
>> My God.
>> I got a special GSV hat that actually
says view from the top on the back,
so thank you so much for your time.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And in my personal life,
I always wear hats, and
I wear three hats always.
One is Chobani, today I decided to come
here with my tenth hat because I'm
extremely passionate about tenth also.
And the third one is my colleagues
from Turkey with no Fenerbahce hat,
my soccer team.
But Chobani's my first love,
so I'll present you this and-
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]